south bend indiana a middle-class town
made famous by the university of notre
dame
just a few miles down the road is jay
willey's restaurant owned by husband and
wife rick and trisha and their friend
john william we're having a great day a
day jay willis this is richard speaking
how may i help you when we took this
over it was making great money
every year consistently this made great
money yo yo let's make money man come on
the day-to-day management of jay willis
is left to john as rick and trisha live
over three hours away where they own
another restaurant who knows what's
gonna happen tonight
we assume that john would be able to
uphold the service standards and the
food quality that we have and it will
continue to make money i can do it and
john has run us in to the ground
john has just let things go i certainly
got off kilter he needs to step up he's
got to be the spark he's got to be the
fire he can't just be back there
[Music]
thinking and contemplating what he's
supposed to do he's got to do it it's
really been tough since we were
struggling and we weren't really
bringing in the cash we don't have a
chef in the kitchen
i'm just here to
to serve what he wants me to serve and
get it out as fast as possible all right
got an order up you get a lot of
complaints about the quality of the food
here and that was just a frozen package
my brother had a little stuffed bird
that was really gross it's not much fun
working in a restaurant when all you
have to experiment with is canned beans
and uh enchilada sauce out of a jar the
standards have declined so far that i'm
not even sure we can revive it i don't
think we'll come back
something sticks
sales have just pretty much flatlined
you know this sucks this is tough now
this place is so depressing
it's hard to even talk about it because
it just makes me want to cry
now it's just slipped into complete
failure
once it closes all the money i put in
everything you know my inheritance
everything it's gone
if we don't make that 22 000 a week
then we're cooked we've cashed in our
401ks
we have no savings and there's nothing
left
some
i mean
if this doesn't work
we will no longer be here
we're going to end up homeless and
it's all because of jay willis
[Music]
but
it's just you know that's it
[Music]
j willie's bar and grill that's fine but
after that ghastly sign at the bottom
whenever a sign's flashing it means
desperation the outside building
well that looks like it closed down 10
years ago let's hope inside is much
better
my god
good afternoon good morning
rick sutton rick good to see you gordon
david benning humphrey david nice to see
you first of all who put that ghastly
sign up outside the one with the
flashing lights i believe our owner john
is john yes he is i can't wait to meet
him very embarrassed to have gordon
ramsay coming here uh he's a
world-renowned chef and we're
not even close to being up to a decent
standard
chef ramsay john william john good to
see you so you are jay willy yes sir
excellent good take a seat
chef this is uh my wife and first name
sorry trisha tricia nice to see you nice
to meet you so trisha and rick yeah and
we're together and john is your partner
yes i'm gonna have a good look at the
menu and uh look forward to catching up
with all three of you i'm really nervous
about what he might order because
there's quite a few items on the menu
and i know he's not gonna like the
pictures in there always nervous when
there's menus with ghastly pictures
[Music]
did you need a few more mama um i'm
gonna order the uh loaded potato pizza
yeah let's go for the famous ribs
i'll go for this pulled pork cheese boat
not a problem thank you thank you very
much thank you so much
say a little prayer trust me i already
said a prayer today okay here's his
order is that
ramsay yes sir
i'm just hoping gordon ramsay isn't too
hard on me because this type of food
wasn't my idea
is
god it's grim in here
sad and grim
and a carpet that looks like
it's had a thousand buffaloes walking
all over it holy [ __ ]
yeah i now have
loaded baked potato pizza lovely thank
you
honey mackerel that's the strangest
pizza i've ever seen
i'm gonna ask
my beloved father to bless my food
[Music]
gentlemen as a quick favor yes yes would
you mind just blessing my food oh yeah
would you sure yeah
if you'd be sick absolutely well good
and gracious god we asked to bless this
food plus chef gordon as he is about to
receive it that it may nourish him we
ask this through christ our lord amen
thank you fingers crossed
god
oh my god
weighs a while man that is a ranch sauce
so they put a ranch dressing on the
pizza yes
it's almost like sort of wallpaper paste
so the pizza sucks
i can see that can i help you john your
pizza has bombs
to be honest i i've tasted the pizza and
it tasted good i didn't see what he was
talking about the ribs gonna be right
huh what do you think
yep
perfect ranch
finally the roots
thank you you're welcome
i was hoping maybe just maybe he'd like
the ribs
chef i've been doing all right here
who's responsible the sauce the chef's
recipe or it's a generic
sauce
it's a shame because it just destroys
the flavor i they are embarrassing
yeah i mean you've got cartilage in
there a mouthful of fat grease on the
outside
that's not even trimmed
sad i agree i'm very bearish a bit like
the restaurant
sad
dude who's serving an untrained man
what do you want to turn around the bat
all rips outside of them
john doesn't get it he's ordering an
inferior rib he's trying to cut corners
i'm just so frustrated that i feel like
banging my head against the
[Music]
sandwich with wall fries thank you enjoy
thank you
[Music]
processed cheese that just like gluing
pulled pork sandwich yeah that's pulled
straight out of the bin sweet taste of
nothing
and
absolutely ghastly
oh dear
we have a pulled pork sandwich
oh um sorry excuse me forgive me father
but oh they have sinned and i
had a respect for you guys you're not
gonna eat that okay okay i don't wanna
go straight to hell
oh man
forgive me they have sinned after saving
the priests from an ungodly meal dear
dear gordon's anxious to meet the
creative minds responsible for the food
jeff gordon are you the chef
we don't really have a chef
how can we not have a chef the recipes
don't really change
everything's prepared the same way you
seem to stand proud of that the menu was
designed to cut a lot of the labor out
cut a lot of labor out and serve
[ __ ] i finally am glad that i have
somebody who agrees with me as far as
the standards on the food john doesn't
listen to me hopefully he'll listen to
gordon i think at midwest cuisine you
think of the excitement in terms of you
know a lovely braised rib a fantastic
sauce the sauce was synthetic we sell a
lot of them is that an excuse to serve
[ __ ] because you said a lot of them are
you that lazy
oh you sell them so [ __ ] it who cares
well sorry the attitude stinks can we
have a chat as owners yes subway yeah
together right now ready hi
how that went about as as i expected
dissatisfied with the answers found in
the kitchen gordon takes the owners
aside hoping to determine the root of
the problem what's wrong with the
business
john
john has to be the leader here
he's not taking any ownership passion
exactly and there's none
i try but without any money the passion
is tough when you
when you're going downhill how much you
aim for it close the door tomorrow
million two
[Music]
so you're you're on your ass
i'll lose the first and only house i've
ever owned yeah we've never owned a
house before any children anywhere no we
can't have kids i'm too busy babysitting
two restaurants trisha she deserves to
have kids too
[Music]
my wife would love to have a child she
deserves it
but we can't do it because
because of jay willis
i mean i just feel so bad because i keep
she's such a beautiful woman i can't
give her what she she deserves
[Music]
i
this wasn't how we planned our lives
we are in the ship
we're screwed
[Music]
is hoping tonight's dinner service will
give him some more answers as to why
this restaurant is failing
hi there welcome to jay willis how you
folks doing
[Music]
i don't want to be today a potential
potato skin sure
i'm thinking the fish sandwich oh got a
16 inch pizza what's that for it's a
special pizza
that's a
frozen dough frozen dough ranch dressing
and then the what are these little fish
food pellets yeah free frozen sausage
that's a static excuse i've ever seen
for a piece of my life
there's no doubt i've taken some i've
cut some corners some of the items are
frozen and that's just from a cost point
of view what's that there
uh cooked chicken i mean it's like cat
food in here well it'll get fully cooked
it's really hard when you're trying to
stay open and what's in here some baked
potatoes
you're going to clean them before they
go in there's balsa
my god that's the i didn't put them in
the oven
[Music]
everything's free
god bless middle america
the quality of the food is just not
there i wouldn't feed it to my dog it's
embarrassing it really is
buy it
defrost it fry it send it you can't call
yourself a restaurant no wonder no one's
coming back
jay willis is doing bad because john is
not upholding the standards put her up
okay thank you the things that i see in
this restaurant it's like he he accepts
it all and rolls up rolled over and died
you think that's too great
so you sent your fish back yes i did
what is that salmon
fish sandwich i don't like it
frozen
holy mackerel
sandwich is like all fat i want
something i'm going to eat okay what
have we got here
what's wrong with that darling she
doesn't like it she doesn't like it
looks like a dog's dinner what is that
oh my god
that is a shock um i'm absolutely
devastated i mean they're cutting
corners but all the wrong places and
john's clueless nobody's responsible for
the kitchen but overall it's an insult
to fast food it's a [ __ ] disgrace
so not that why the ribs back
these were too mushy
i i don't know what to say
food just put in a process line more
food coming back has been sent out i
mean it's almost like you guys have just
you know given up
i'm standing here in my jaw on the floor
this was definitely humiliating
eye-opening embarrassing gordon ramsay's
appearance at the restaurant may have
brought in some extra customers we're
not eating we're going to eat some
animals but unfortunately the food has
scared many of them away jay willis is
doing bad because john's killing off the
business that's bottom line
[Music]
after a miserable dinner service gordon
decides that he needs to meet with not
only the owners but with the entire
staff we have some serious issues back
there i wanted you all together to get
an idea of how you felt
and how does it make you feel when you
serve that food
embarrassing
embarrassing
i'm amazed you guys put up with it it's
getting harder and harder every day
because the paychecks keep getting
slimmer and slimmer
and our sales are dropping like a rock
because of john's inability to make
anything happen
rick you're not here you're killing this
man over here saying that he's not good
at anything they wouldn't be here if
this restaurant wasn't dying so you
don't you can't blame this on me i'm not
blaming you on you there's stuff
everywhere i'm saying don't blame
everything on him
yeah you're never here
i cannot come down here and run this
restaurant we live three
and a half hours away
john has to do it has to come from john
the point the point is you're just not
helping them you're blaming john for it
and it's wrong he's here he's here every
no this is our business too i have
mouths at home to feed nail me to the
cross
rick's ridiculous i really just want a
pun trick sometimes to be honest this
whole issue is not what the problem is
with this restaurant the problem here
whether we all like it or not is the
food sucks
and it's not fresh
and even frozen food is handled badly
all three of you should be ashamed to
stand there and
allow it to go on is it time to get
somebody else in to run it i mean you
know
have you had enough
i believe it's still in me i just need
somebody to help i need somebody to
cover my back
all three of you need to wake up
and wake up quickly
after the staff meeting gordon takes a
peek into the kitchen storage
and uncovers the unthinkable this is
basic hygiene
it doesn't get drained and the blood is
set out in a warm kitchen it's not even
cold
john there's more
when chef gordon pulled those potato
skins out i knew that he had found
something that i wasn't gonna like say
hold on a bit that's gonna be deep fried
tomorrow yeah
that's really gonna make it taste better
right
potatoes are rot and we're sat here
wondering why the business is on his ass
it starts at the top john
it's called responsibility no wonder
you've given up
i've been in denial and i've lowered my
standards and it takes somebody like a
gordon ramsay to come in and wake you up
rotten tomatoes
soft rotten
the rotten peppers the whole box is
wrong
i wanted to crawl under the table and
hide my face so people wouldn't
associate me with such crap if you
seriously aren't honest
with yourself that you are starting
again then we start again
well we'll do whatever it takes
i'd be [ __ ] ashamed
you sure if i'm embarrassed
[Music]
where do i start with the problems in
this restaurant the staff have got their
issues but that's irrelevant the big
problem is the food and the quicker they
all get up to speed with how [ __ ] the
food is the better because that is
embarrassing
john
yeah you're gonna pitch all this crap
chef ramsay's gave us a challenge to see
if we're committed to changing this food
and making it better it's a fresh start
for every everybody everything right
oh my god are they taking all the food
out
there
i guess we start new tomorrow i guess so
i was absolutely ecstatic that he was
throwing everything away it has been a
huge complaint for a long time so how
does it feel to throw their way does it
feel like a purging yeah i have to now
it could let it go just let it all go
it's a huge amount of food that we threw
away this evening john does it feel good
yes
we're starting fresh and that means
getting rid of everything
when i finally saw john throwing out
food that he would have otherwise saved
i knew that we were taking the first
step to making progress okay this is
fresh start to a fresh day
after the owners took it upon themselves
to clean out their restaurant this
morning gordon is looking for the owners
to bear their souls
[Music]
good morning
how are we good
tough day yesterday
cleaned out the restaurant cleaned out
the kitchen and
i'd like to think we started a new
chapter
i want to chat with you
i want to clean out our conscience
rick go first yeah
let's go
[Music]
okay
clearing your conscience is about
reaching inside and being honest with
yourself yeah
biggest fear is what
my
fate
rests in john's hands
and that really scares me i want this to
work desperately i just haven't got much
to work with that's what i'm struggling
with most people who face depression the
problems i have give up and i refuse to
do that i'll fight till the last dog
dies
i like your determination you know
i appreciate chef
who'd you turn to i don't have
anybody to voice my concerns so
it's been tough
everything's pretty much inside that's
not easy
truthfully i'm just
struggling to find
an internal flight
have you got it because
i don't feel it
with
support
i've got it inside me
it's there
what i saw last night was huge
what i felt last night was huge
and what i feel this morning i'm ready
to go look forward to seeing you later
trish what do you want to see happen
i want john to be jay
willy if i could take half a rick and
put it in john's body
i think
things would be a little bit better he'd
have more enthusiasm a little bit more
passion
he's just lacking in that thank you
trisha thanks
having gained a deeper understanding of
the owner's situation
gordon is ready to start implementing
his plan beginning in the place that
needs it the most come through the
kitchen look at all the ingredients
what's that for
barbecue sauce excellent barbecue sauce
first off garlic ketchup chili
ground coffee soy sauce spice first off
olive oil yeah quite generous on the
olive oil that gives the shine on the
sauce yeah it was an absolutely amazing
experience working with gordon ramsay
nicely caramelized i'm just in utter awe
of his ability as a chef
and then
a molasses that gives it its barbecue
flavor okay that
is that barbecue sauce we're serving
fresh homemade barbecue sauce tonight
in addition to the new jay willy's
signature barbecue sauce gordon
introduces a new hamburger special that
jay willis has never offered before one
made with fresh ingredients homemade
burger so with a homemade barbecue sauce
and fresh cut homemade fries are we
ready yes
as customers arrive just follow me
the kitchen prepares the new burger
specials we're serving real food tonight
and everyone seems eager to make
tonight's service a success we have a
homemade fresh ground beef burger i am
gonna have a burger
yep thank you got your ticket go ahead
and uh get those fries coming four
orders you can do it
tonight prove it yes
it's a half hour into dinner service
kobe's are done and the new burger
specials are flying out of the kitchen
it's really fresh isn't it that barbecue
sauce smells good it's incredible in
there the difference in the energy is
extraordinary and it just goes to prove
one single thing on the menu freshly
made homemade sounds like hotcakes
oh boy walking in we got three chef
specials going well done the tickets
kept coming in and i got real nervous i
could barely read the tickets two medium
wells and a medium take that two well
done five mid well i thought you said
two mediums
i'll make it make it a medium well dude
i need you to tell me what i have dude
because now i'm all [ __ ] up i was
frustrated i wanted to throw stuff i
wasn't okay with the organization at all
[ __ ] dude i don't know what's going on
i'm [ __ ] up burgers is this burger
you gave you said the well done no it
was you said midwell it's done dude
right got an order up thank you
despite the confusion over the burgers
burger burger burger they are rushed out
to the dining room a new burger and the
customers are in for an unpleasant
surprise
how many burgers we got left uh one more
burger okay christian
86 burger yes yes stop all right yes yes
make sure everybody knows david please
yes sir chris i need two re-cooks medium
on the fly
yeah if we can't make that burger we're
completely out of ground beef oh my gosh
all of a sudden burgers came back
undercooked overcooked and it's fat we
don't have it we don't have it we don't
have it we got a burger coming back
supposed to be well done no we're out
unbelievable i got another recook this
is ridiculous we're all kind of freaking
out you know it was scary burger sitting
over here burger's here burger's here
and i don't know what to do
it's an hour into dinner service and the
kitchen has run out of its special fresh
hamburgers we're completely out of
ground beef and the burgers that have
been served are unfortunately coming
back
with no one taking control of the
situation i don't know what to do the
kitchen and the restaurant for that
matter is in a state of confusion dave
could you all grab us a package of the
old burgers sweet sourdough get a buns
we got to do what we got to do get them
out the burger they're going to love it
anyway sourdough or butter oh yes
i was just going to keep trying to put
the food out going back to regular fries
so we started making the burgers on
sourdough bread and using the frozen
french fries and the frozen ground beef
dude this i can't serve this can i i
don't care if there'll be one i mean i
guess i have to it doesn't
matter
in an effort to make good on the orders
order up ashley a desperate kitchen
staff lowers its standards and starts
delivering cheap substitutes sorry about
that
your bun
that is all we have is a bun and the
disappointment combined with the long
wait is too much for one customer to
bear i'm really gonna try it
would you like something
else you ran out of the mud
[Music]
what is that pile of [ __ ] what's that
for the special burgers what
whoa hey guys why is that burger on
there the processed one
john
why did the 86 it when i said take it
off
we were dropping the standards just a
bit but we were under tremendous
pressure because there were so many
people out there that were anxious to
try the food we haven't got the right
buns we shouldn't be serving it and
what's the point in lowering the
standard just to keep it on
it doesn't make [ __ ] sense
boys that's gotta go bad
he's afraid of pink sorry now i got two
paper plates around some sort of big
meatball
how do you run out of potatoes
what do they say
it's disgusting unedible unbelievable
such a shame because we got off to a
really good start but then standard
started dropping but john and rick
accepted the standards dropping and they
just were happy to send slop so a real
sad ending into the evening because
right now we're back to square one
[Music]
should be ashamed
i busted my balls all day today thinking
a way of marketing this place and
putting it back on the map
oh [ __ ] it
can't do it
don't give up on my [ __ ]
i'm not gonna do anything
until i'm 100 convinced
that you guys are ready to turn the
corner i seriously want to help
i need to know from each and every one
of you
that you're ready to commit i commit i
do i'm ready to commit
okay see in the morning
i'm here early
taking the staff's word of commitment to
heart gordon moves forward with his plan
to transform jay willis from a dreary
restaurant into a more inviting
establishment
right guys good morning how are you
feeling can you see
right now awesome does that look great j
willy's barbecue awesome yes yeah this
is gonna be the best barbecue house in
town
yes rick what's the matter thank you but
if we don't execute tonight
this is for [ __ ] you're absolutely right
well we are gonna play dress friends
tonight and
let's get positive come on i am okay
good you own part of this place so i'm
going to be looking towards you to drive
this forward yes yes
last night the minute you guys left yeah
my team arrived i've been working all
night let's go
ah
yep
[Music]
now come through
first of all new wallpaper new paint
final tablecloths yes it's a new place
oh my gosh
it's
beautiful i'm so overwhelmed
there are no words
there are words
look at it and this oh my gosh
that's just amazing
the breakfast started to give you some
warmth oh my gosh it's classy yeah
it was overwhelming for me just
everything blew me away warm vibrant and
exciting
carpet first time in 15 years hey john
keep it clean yes
yes and i'm not sticking to the floor
john what'd you think it's awesome yes
awesome rick what'd you think that we
don't deserve this what do you mean
don't deserve it huh smack him i
i just want to yell and scream
woohoo
this is too much
too much every top bbq house in the
country
has the best sauce and that is what
we're going to be famous for look over
there
on site homemade hey exclusive and when
people come to visit south bend jay
willis the best barbecue house in town
oh my gosh
i want to stay in this restaurant i want
to spend money in here today's a moving
experience both in my career as well as
my attitude
and i just there's so much potential i
just can't wait with the staff energized
by the changes to the restaurant gordon
now unveils his plan for the food 75
items on the last menu no wonder we can
control it
hey it's now in half it's
fresh and it's gonna be quick
from the homemade burger the blt to the
pool pork potato skins no processed
cheese anywhere barbecue chicken spicy
chicken wings and legs yes at this point
i think with the momentum that chef
ramsay has given us we are now committed
to making this thing right i'm going to
do something i've never ever done before
i've had my concerns about the lack of
strength in the kitchen they need a
proper training and a proper insight to
what's going on
i'm bringing in not one not two but four
chefs
scott kim michael please and april
this kind of tuition has never been done
before
it's awesome chef ramsay let us know
that he was there for us
we will be ready for the relaunch of jay
willis tonight
let's go
jay willis has come a long way in a
matter of days oh my gosh it's awesome
and it's only minutes from relaunch
tonight it's comeback night yes yes
so john you've got to motivate the place
push it through its highs and lows don't
just do it for chef do it for the gipper
yes
the gipper okay guys let's go we're
opening four minutes yeah let's go yes
let's go
from side your coleslaw looks a little
different now chef ramsay is hoping his
chefs will give jay willie's kitchen
staff the support it needs to make this
critical night a success welcome to gee
woolies welcome to new jay willis i'll
take the baby back ribs yo yo kitchen
get us wrong let's go we're gonna be
busy i'm so apprehensive because if we
aren't perfect then none of this matters
i might as well just get in my car and
drive home let's rock this [ __ ] out
dave you got to expedite you're insane
you've got to stay connected
come on let's go let's get this [ __ ] out
of all my being i didn't want to fail i
was a little scared order up 122. these
guys have never been held to these
standards yeah
barbecue chicken
good sauce difference it's good
it's all really good
sean that's it that's it yeah
coffee's a good start um vibrant in
there food looking good but it's not how
you start it's how you
finish how are we
the no bacon on the potato skins was not
cool
damn damn damn
yeah let me check on your entrees nice
to see you all yes yeah
andres will be fair
okay guys
the skins they just sent was that
there's no bacon in there please
concentrate yes sir
cream corner mac it's all good no dave
we do not send a dirty plate we're
getting busy guys we're starting to slip
come on yes sir oh my gosh chef ramsay
busted me out you know there's a little
barbecue sauce in the corner
get it out this is our ticket time
i'm so hungry now we all are very hungry
it's the heart of dinner service and in
spite of the pressure to get dishes out
unbelievable gordon insists on the staff
maintaining its standards kept the
customers waiting we can't keep them
waiting for the fans yes gadget
what's over 14
time in seven o'clock
there you go all right 114 steve
we're waiting for an hour 114. that's
our next check okay come on come on come
on
let's push it steve come on man
it's 8 30. it is it's late and i'm tired
john
sanders come on yeah
the kitchen really got behind part of it
was my fault because it was overwhelming
for me come on guys can we stop pushing
food around the outside of the plate
they can't eat off the rim of the plate
guys yes chef okay
we can't drop standards
last [ __ ] time okay one's fine twice
slightly pissed three times take your
jacket off and [ __ ] off yeah yes thank
you now clean it john as the backup in
the kitchen continues to grow john turns
his attention to the potential disaster
in the front of the house i want drinks
and i need food she trusts me
i uh i gotta talk to these people yeah
and uh okay just trust me you name them
my name jay willy jay
that's me jake john man i need some
proof okay okay i'm gonna do my best how
long is the wait it's running pretty
late right now
let's worry about our standards and not
worry about that all right john
why are you going to run out with that
john
look at look look look
you taste that then and let's think of a
nice pile of shed yes customers are
waiting but are we happy with that
you are happy with no i mean come on
then standards
there's so much stress the guests were
starting to get pretty tired of waiting
i did drop my standard and i shouldn't
have shut he's ready to go home
we'll get free desserts right uh i'll do
my best to take care of you i had so
many people were upset and i was
embarrassing i i was just i was ready to
pack up and leave at that point we i'm
sorry we cooking fresh to order
come on guys tonight's too important to
[ __ ] it up come on
i'll be back
come on please dave no one's getting a
handle of this and i'm getting [ __ ]
irritated here
all right josh
the thought of crumbling
existed most of the night but the
feeling was i hope it just doesn't
explode
i'm leaving two hours
no food and it's just tough
i just want you know
this isn't gonna lie
come on guys
tonight jay willy's kitchen is being
tested like it's never been tested
before do not send a dirty place and
although the standards are better than
ever it's been way too long i'll be back
one customer
is fed up with the weight two hours
no food right and it's just tough
i just want you know
this isn't gonna last
i'm leaving
joe break
two seconds let's both your minute i
know tables have walked out and we can't
just all walk around with the heads on
the floor
come on then dig deeper tables are
backed up it's not the end of the world
is it we still got to keep it going
right
but if you give up they give up i'm
sorry
play to the very end means the last
ticket i'm with it okay come on guys
let's go we got it we're gonna have to
push the staff or else this whole thing
is just gonna fall apart wait a minute
this is cold this can't go out that's
all we needed [ __ ] you sounds just like
gordon come on
okay
no problem with the owners stepping up
the staff gets inspired which in turn
motivates manager dave come on let's
let's calm down and focus we need some
rams and checking baby serve it no i i
do feel that i'm gonna have to step up
and take charge and get her done six
combos i need now
all right let's do it
full rack tri-tip entree and a half rack
let's worry about our standards you hear
that
right here they should have ribs are hot
oh they're hot they're beautiful
service please come on you in my pit
let's go the kitchen has shifted into
high gear and with one final push the
highly anticipated food is on its way to
the customers mine's very good tender
spicy all right very best i've ever had
thank you
appreciate it all right got an order up
now we're moving now we're doing good
let's keep it up
food's coming out right
i believe that john he's realized he
will not accept substandard quality
good deal all right we got a dining room
full of locusts man they need everything
except for the plate every plate i've
picked up has been cleaned awesome
all we got to do is get these tickets
out man just this last batch oh i think
i see the light at the end of the tunnel
folks
now i i don't feel like i'm a man
on an island alone i know that the rick
and trish will be here to support me
that food looked beautiful yeah
this hamburger is the best
there's no word to wait i guess
and we will be back
with the locals seal of approval jay
willis is on the road to recovery
it was so nice to see clean plates
coming back yes yes
and we were so busy
165 customers
i know there was some complaints and it
was difficult but
the kitchen got slammed and more
importantly we held on to our standards
and now that we know how to do it don't
stop
okay they won't let me no no no
chef ramsay has taught us have a passion
and make perfect and don't
accept any excuses
john if they offer you a little less
expensive cheese
no no no
no no no no no no
the staff
has changed john has changed
i'm overwhelmed
with sincere
thanks for chef ramsay without him we
would not be here now what's the
feedback from the dining room
the word is starting to spread
definitely you've got your foot on the
ladder it's really important that you
continue climbing you all did a bloody
good job and i'm really proud of you
bye guys bye ladies thank you very much
john has a new bounce and a step he has
to know that we're on his side and that
we're all in this together and it's just
not him taking on the world it's all of
us
and get ready because we're gonna take
on the world
wow
it's been very interesting for me to
come to the heart of america and meet a
really nice bunch of hard-working humble
individuals but when i first arrived i
honestly thought the restaurant was
beyond salvation but tonight showed a
little glimmer of hope so
long may continue and haven't helped
them
in the days that followed everyone at
jay willis worked hard to keep their
standards up do it start hauling out
thank you gentlemen and continued to
perfect their barbecue sauce
a sauce that earned jay willie's first
prize at the college football hall of
fame ribs cook-off
with a taste of success the staff at jay
willis continues to work together to
make its new barbecue house a success
you